throughout the past years tech innovator
and ceo of tesla elon musk has made a
name for himself as constantly being at
the forefront of revolutionizing our
technological reality his ventures cover
a vast spectrum of the tech industry and
with successes like tesla and spacex
under his belt it's no surprise that the
world tends to hold its breath to see
what he's got coming next that's why
experts believe that the talk of a new
tesla smartphone dubbed the model pi
could be a major game changer for the
entire smartphone industry welcome to
simply tech where today we're going to
be going through the model pi tesla's
next big thing we'll look at just what
features exactly we expect to see that
will set the model pi apart from the
rest of the smartphone market design the
designs for the model pi have been put
together by antonio derosa a top tech
designer who has been responsible for
some of apple's most lauded design
concepts with his design derosa pays
homage to the technological innovations
of tesla starlink and spacex the phone
is set to look recognizable enough with
the same touch screen interface that
most modern smartphones make use of
today the concept designs show that the
model pi will sport four high
performance cameras on its rear similar
to the apple iphone 12 color scheme and
battery life aesthetically the model pi
is set to have a color changing coating
on its casting as the creators have
developed a photochromic coating that
changes appearance in various light
settings as to be expected with a tesla
product the developers are working to
incorporate a solar charging panel that
can be used to provide the phone with
power this makes the model pi a
particularly low maintenance choice when
it comes to smartphones as it can
essentially charge itself around the
clock the front screen of the phone is
designed with an ultrasonic touch lock
to speed up access to all the apps and
services needed at their fingertips
global satellite connectivity well
tesla's recent forays into the world of
satellite technology are certainly going
to play a major role in the development
of their smartphone technology satellite
connectivity is one hurdle that every
smartphone manufacturer has to tackle
and tesla is hoping to use their
experience in this field to provide
networking that is unmatched by other
smartphone models beginning in 2018
tesla began to launch the network of low
orbit satellites that make up the
starlink satellite network as of 2021
the starlink internet constellation is
now made up of over 1600 individual
satellites and will eventually consist
of many thousands of mass-produced
satellites providing connectivity across
most of the globe as of october 2021
there are over 90 000 people connected
to the starlink network via their
internet subscription elon musk has
stated that he hopes to reach 500 000
users within the next year using the
starlink network the tesla model pi
phone would be expected to provide
upload and download speeds of 210
megabytes per second the model pi would
be linked strictly to the starlink
network for its connectivity camera as
far as the renders show the phone will
house at least four cameras on the rear
of the phone these four cameras will be
aligned in a square shaped pattern
similar to the apple iphone 12. the
front camera is not yet visible in the
concept renders but experts are hedging
their bets that it will be placed
alongside the solar charging panel at
the top of the device hybrid
technologies a tesla ecosystem
throughout 2021 tesla has grown over 157
percent and this rapid growth has been
bringing more and more high profile
attention to the full scope of elon
musk's projects between the successful
launches of spacex the rollout of
several new tesla car models ventures
into solar power generation and even
pioneering cyborg ai with a side company
neuralink it seems as if there's no
emerging sector that musk isn't eager to
get a foothold in bringing together all
of these technologies in one smartphone
is guaranteed to revolutionize an
industry product that most carry in
their pockets at all times connecting
these technologies will rely heavily on
the starlink satellite network by the
end of 2021 musk has stated that he aims
to connect the satellite network to a
range of automated electric vehicles
such as planes and trucks once vehicles
are connected to the starlink network
this would allow for the model pi to
connect directly with the vehicles
bypassing the need for the smartphone to
use its sim and connect with local
cellular towers this will see tesla
products more directly integrated with
each other than any other network
technologies on the market connect to
the road naturally we can expect to see
the model pi being used to manage the
tesla app which can be used to control a
range of tesla products using the app
drivers can automatically operate their
vehicles without the need for any direct
control or manual keys as the
self-driving abilities of tesla model
cars only increases drivers will be able
to control more and more of their
journey from their cell phones a new
approach to finance like many emerging
smartphones on the market it can be
expected that the model pi will be set
to function as a digital wallet of sorts
for its owners as elon musk is no
stranger to digital finance being one of
the minds behind the digital transfer
giant paypal users can be sure that this
technology will be well integrated into
their smartphones aside from storing
traditional currency and acting as a
platform for online banking the tesla
model pi phone will also allow users to
engage in the cryptocurrency market of
which musk himself has been a major
proponent of tesla helped to further
popularize the use of bitcoin by
allowing their customers to purchase
their electric vehicles via the
cryptocurrency in the past years musk
has single-handedly had a giant
influence over the cryptocurrency market
taking dogecoin ahead of bitcoin and
ethereum in its growth throughout 2021
as colonizing mars is one of elon musk's
top priorities tesla has gone so far to
announce that the tesla model pi will be
able to be used to mine the mars coin a
cryptocurrency intended as a test bed
for experimentation with technologies
that will help early colonists on the
red planet this essentially means that
users of the tesla model pi will be able
to earn money simply by using their
smartphones to mine this futuristic new
cryptocurrency cyborg potential as the
model pi will help to integrate finance
communication transport and many other
areas of daily life it may also be
possible to integrate with its owners
beginning in 2016 elon musk helped to
launch neuralink a venture that aims to
marry the fields of ai and machine
learning with neuroscience neuralink's
projects are famously kept rather
hush-hush but one of the major aims of
the project that elon musk has spoken
about is the development of a brain
machine interface that would allow
humans to directly communicate with
machines the device will be surgically
implanted into the brain and allow
humans to directly communicate with and
even control their gadgets with just
their minds musk and his team also hope
that the neurolink will be able to
monitor prevent and even cure a range of
diseases musk has stated that in theory
such a device would be able to perform
seeming miracles such as restoring
eyesight to those with damaged optic
nerves essentially being able to fix
anything wrong with the brain
installation of the device is performed
by highly precise robots as musk has
stated that the procedure is too precise
and delicate for even the most skilled
of human hands to accomplish smartphone
users would be able to monitor their own
brain activity and neurological health
from their devices virtually placing the
key to their mind at their fingertips as
the neuralink project progresses further
its technology will be integrated with
the model pi meaning that someday in the
future you might be able to answer your
phone simply by thinking about it launch
and release the exact launch and release
date of the tesla model pi phone remains
yet unknown as do various other elements
of the smartphone's features the public
has not yet been given indication as to
the internal processing capacities or
storage capabilities set to be housed in
the new smartphone although given the
ambitious flare shown in all other tesla
products we imagine that they are going
to try to push the limit with this new
piece of technology with its impressive
range of interconnectivity both with
starlink and other products on the tesla
line as well as its futuristic design
features and solar charging panel the
model pi promises to be the perfect
gadget for optimizing the technical side
of life given that it's a tesla product
we can expect sustainability to be a
major feature of its production although
it has yet to be announced just where
production of the model pi would take
place given the recent collaboration
between apple and spacex for developing
new smartphone technology that is more
highly integrated with satellite
technology and suitable for space travel
we can expect to see the best of both
companies technology make its way into
the hands of model pi users what the
model pi means for tesla since its
foundation in 2003 tesla has had its
fair share of ups and downs in fact in
the mid 2010s things weren't looking so
good for the automobile giant their car
manufacturing lines found difficulty
supplying the necessary machine parts
there were major losses to their
executive talent pool and high profile
disputes among investors though at one
point it seemed the company may be on
the brink of bankruptcy elon musk's
innovative attitude and a series of new
releases helped to revitalize the
company to unprecedented heights the
road ahead tesla is currently more
valuable than ever and has in fact
overtaken toyota and volkswagen to
become the car company with the greatest
market cap in the entire world over 795
billion us dollars it is as the company
is soaring to new heights that elon musk
has decided to bring tesla's innovation
to this entirely new frontier by
announcing the tesla model pi
unsurprisingly the idea of a tesla built
smartphone is sending shockwaves through
the design and tech communities with
everyone eagerly awaiting more
information with baited breath as
further information is released we are
set to get a clearer idea of just what
to expect from the model pi and whether
or not elon musk can incorporate all of
his tech innovations into a single
smartphone with the power to
revolutionize the entire market